we have these  huge companies powered by  incredibly complex algorithms that even  the people who manage them don't  understand how they work right and these  are you know driving people towards  content rabbit holes etc  that are forming opinions  and often translating into behaviors in  the real world right you can't deny the  real world ramifications that we're  seeing getting played out through  politics  and just the decline or the denigration  of public discourse and decorum across  the world it is changing our behavior  whether we like it or not or how  resistant we are to that idea because  it's an assault on our agency and  sentence and all of that this is  happening and so  please you know re-evaluate your  relationship with these platforms you  have to shoulder responsibility for  how you use it